partidazo y de Brasil contra Corea un
resultado espectacular y un primer
tiempo lleno de goles que se ha vivido
aquí en el centro de Río de Janeiro con
mucha alegría con mucha esperanza la
palabra mágica es hexa el sexto
campeonato que Brasil espera conquistar
parece que los brasileños Por fin se
están reconciliando con una selección
que hace ocho años perdía contra
Alemania en aquel traje con siete a uno
hace cuatro años vivimos aquí en Río un
cierto trauma un cierto desencanto pero
ahora está volviendo la alegría el
entusiasmo las calles pintadas todo el
mundo está muy esperadosos para el
próximo partido que va a ser contra
Croacia un equipo de respecto recordamos
que en 2018 se enfrentó a Francia en la
final y me gustaría destacar un tema
estoy con una camiseta azul que es nueva
de este año recordamos que todo el mundo
conoce la bandera de Brasil verde
amarilla pero el azul es el el color de
esta bandera y hay una polémica con la
camiseta porque los últimos cuatro años
una parte de Brasil se quejaba de que
los funcionaristas la habían secuestrado
sale esta camisa la que estoy llevando
Yo hoy y es para aquellos hinchas que
quieren apoyar a su selección de fútbol
sin ser confundidos con los
bolsonaristas que recordamos siguen
acampado en muchos cuarteles militares
en todo Brasil